[Música]
muchísimas gracias
con este anticipo cualquiera cualquiera
lo hace bien
os voy a contar una historia
la cosa gustó al principio a que os
apetece que cuente una historia
a todos nos gusta que nos cuenten
historias
house los antiguos griegos los antiguos
romanos esos a los que eso que conocemos
como la civilización clásica nos han
dejado un conjunto de historias de todo
tipo de mitos de leyendas tan
extraordinario tan cuestionado tan
ingente que nos resulta fascinante
conocerles
y porque nos resulta fascinante
conocerlas en primer lugar obviamente
porque a todos nos gusta que nos cuenten
historias a todos nos gusta que nos
cuenten historias desde la antigüedad
clásica pero desde mucho antes también
la gente se reunía para contar historias
yo estoy completamente convencido de que
el hombre necesita no solamente respirar
y comer y necesita me quiere cuenten
historias
y eso lo hemos convertido en algo
somático porque porque precisamente de
eso depende que nos alejemos de la
condición animal de que seamos capaces
de transferir nuestra experiencia a las
generaciones siguientes y en la medida
en que transferimos esa experiencia a
través de historias que contamos de
mitos que conformamos de
interpretaciones que hacemos del mundo
que nos rodea las nuevas generaciones no
tienen que empezar de cero pueden ya
empezar con la experiencia acumulada de
las generaciones anteriores
y os pongo en esa imagen un cuadro de un
pintor grande es alma tadema y del siglo
19 principios del siglo 20 en donde
representa al poeta al ceo de lesbos
cantando contando sus historias sus
poemas assafo la primera poetisa de la
historia de occidente la primera poetisa
que nosotros conocemos que la escucha
interesada ella y sus compañeras de su
cortejo de su grupo de amigas
está embelesado escuchándole ahora nos
encanta que nos cuenten historias bueno
pues en el cine los niños y además esas
historias frecuentemente también tienen
o están nutridas están impregnadas de
estos mitos clásicos de estas leyendas
que vienen de la antigüedad grecolatina
todos habéis visto quizás el hércules de
walt disney o por supuesto la troya de
brad pitt ya sabéis que el héroe que
conquistó troya era brad pitt no era
aquí listo
nos sigue nos sigue fastidiando estas
historias nos parecen divertidas nos
parecen entretenidas nos parecen
interesantes nos parecen emocionantes y
nos gusta quemar más cuenta
pero también
estas historias son importantes para
nosotros por otro motivo estas historias
han impregnado de una manera que muy
probablemente nosotros no somos
absolutamente conscientes de ello han
impregnado de una manera extraordinaria
todo lo que es el mundo referencial de
occidente de nuestra civilización porque
están insertas en cualquier producto
cultural que nuestra civilización ha
construido bien sea una cerámica griega
como ésta que os pongo ahí a la
izquierda donde se nos cuenta la
historia de como eneas sacó a su anciano
padre tullido que no podía andar and
kisses de troya para salvarlo de la
destrucción o ese mosaico romano que
vemos al lado de la villa de la olmeda
en palencia donde se nos narra como
aquiles se vistió de mujer para no ir a
la guerra de troya porque sabía que iba
a morir en ella y como fue descubierto
mediante un ardid
del héroe ulises
esas historias impregnando nuestro mundo
medieval nuestros manuscritos medievales
están llenos también de todos estos
mitos que nos vienen de la antigüedad
clásica y por ejemplo os pongo una
ilustración de una escena de un gran
poema clásico de la eneida en donde se
ve como eneas ese héroe que se acaba su
padre a hombros de troya pues está
consumando una relación que no es
adecuada con la reina dido que lo ha
acogido después de un sufragio en una
prueba después de una cacería oa la
derecha pues otras ilustraciones
medievales de esta misma obra
obras en las que obviamente se gastaba
muchísimo dinero porque había mucho
interés copiar eso dibujar eso decorarlo
con pan de oro cuesta muchísimo dinero y
eso se hacía porque había mucho interés
en esas historias y no digamos cuando
llegamos al renacimiento estaba en
nuestros museos llenos de historias
pintadas que vienen de esos mitos
clásicos como en este caso esta danae y
la lluvia de oro del museo del prado
pintado por tiziano o como no esta
historia de la fragua de vulcano apolo
comunicándole al dios efecto que su
mujer le está engañando medusa que se
está acostando con marte y el pobre
efecto no se lo cree él por estar
trabajando y apolo está llevándose
porque en el fondo era él el que quería
tener relaciones con convenios o esta
otra de rubens en donde se nos
representa esa reina dido a la que hemos
visto haciendo
manitas con líneas dentro de una cueva
cómo se suicida cuando eneas la abandona
para conseguir para seguir su camino
según le había marcado el destino o
todos conocéis también más adelante como
goya pinta a saturno devorando a sus
hijos el tiempo dios cronos de los
griegos el dios del tiempo como devora a
sus criaturas o incluso en nuestros días
pues en el arte actual
picasso y muchísimos artistas pues le
han dedicado también una enorme atención
a estos mitos clásicos bueno la
literatura de occidente está llena de
constantes referencias a estos mitos
clásicos los han recontado una y otra
vez ahí pongo un famosísimo soneto de
las filas o de la vega dedicado
precisamente a como apolo intento
unirse a la ninfa de acné a la derecha
la misma historia pero contada por
bernini en una escultura prodigiosa en
donde dafne que se niega a unirse a ese
dios que está siendo acosada por ese
dios pues implora a los dioses que la
protejan y los días en la convierte en
el laurel el laurel siempre que veis un
laurel
debéis pensar que estáis viendo a una
mujer que se negó a ser violada a ser
acosada ni siquiera por un dios y se
convirtió en ese árbol pero nosotros
tenemos esos mitos clásicos en nuestro
en nuestro ambiente cercano y muchas
veces ni siquiera reparamos en ellos si
todos conocéis la estatua de cibeles la
fuente de cibeles y en madrid que no la
pusieron ahí para que el real madrid
celebrará sus triunfos sino que la
pusieron antes de que existiera la real
madrid y por un motivo que no viene
ahora al caso contar y bueno pues un
poquito más allá tenéis la fuente de
apolo y un poquito más abajo tenéis la
fuente de neptuno que es para que los
del atlético de madrid pues puedan
también celebrar sus escasísimos
triunfos de ver aquí
pero también ellos tienen derecho y
también tienen derecho a hacerlo con un
referente clásico
yo soy del granado esta tarde le va a
ganar al real madrid
e
nuestros parques nuestros jardines están
llenos también de referencias a estos
mitos clásicos ahí tenéis por ejemplo
como polifemo el cíclope polifemo está
descubriendo los amores de acis y
galatea él está enamorado de galatea
garatea no le gusta ese polifemo que es
gigantón que tiene un solo ojo y
polifemo le va a lanzar una piedra acys
para aplastarlo es una manera de quitar
pretendientes o rivales en el amor un
poco un poco expeditiva pero esta está
en el parque de luxemburgo de parís o
todos tenéis en nuestra imagen también
este magnífico prometeo que hay algo que
france antes de nueva york el ejemplo
del héroe que le dio a los hombres la
capacidad de separarse de los animales
de iniciar una vida diferente con el uso
precisamente del fuego le robó el fuego
a los dioses por eso lleva esa antorcha
y se lo dio a los hombres para que los
hombres pudieran evolucionar el fuego la
energía
como elemento que convierte a los
hombres en unos seres vivos diferentes a
todos los demás que existe en la pero
estos mitos clásicos están también a
veces de una manera muy sutil e
introducidos dentro de nuestra de
nuestras vidas y ahí tenéis el escudo de
españa con unas columnas y unas bandas
que las rodean son las columnas de
hércules son esas columnas que colocó
ese héroe
grandioso hércules al que hemos visto
antes en la película de walt disney
alguna de ellas es el peñón de gibraltar
la otra está al otro lado del estrecho
bueno pues eso está en el escudo de
españa y de ahí
procede el símbolo del dólar el símbolo
del dólar son esas dos columnas del
escudo de españa y esas banderas que lo
que lo rodean a todos vosotros cuando os
habéis acercado a trabajar con los
ordenadores sabréis que hay que tener
siempre mucho cuidado con los caballos
de troya
como también esta historia del caballo
de troya ese ardid que se utiliza que
utilizaron los griegos inventado por
ulises para tomar la ciudad de troya
pues introduciendo dentro de ellos
dentro del caballo pero los guerreros
más valientes de los aqueos y cuando los
troyanos creían que eso era un regalo
pues se dieron cuenta de que era un
regalo demasiado tarde un regalo
envenenado un regalo que provocó que la
ciudad cayera cuando no había podido
caer no lo habían podido tomar los
saqueos en diez años que había durado la
guerra ahí os pongo la representación
más antigua de ese caballo de troya una
cerámica griega del siglo 7 antes de
cristo- veis ahí el caballito y las
ventanitas por donde asoman esos
guerreros y bueno ya la derecha pues esa
misma recreación
la película de troya que hemos visto
antes
pero además de esos mitos nos gusten y
además que nos diviertan de que nos
emocionen además de que esos mitos están
presentes en todas las manifestaciones
culturales de occidente a nosotros nos
gustan también los mitos clásicos porque
nos hablan de nosotros porque nos dan
respuesta a muchísimas cosas que vivimos
a muchísimas situaciones que nos
encontramos en la vida
bueno no hace falta recordar aquí que el
mismísimo según freud cuando quiso
ponerle el nombre a uno de los de los
síndromes que estudiaba pues le llamo el
complejo de edipo refiriéndose de nuevo
a ese mundo referencia al clásico que
compartíamos todos en occidente
curiosamente para los antiguos griegos y
romanos
la inteligencia y sobre todo la
inteligencia en lo que la inteligencia
nos permite planificar el futuro
anticiparnos al futuro
estaba representada por una diosa no por
un dios por una diosa por una potencia
femenina la inteligencia la diosa palas
atenea
ella era la que regía todas las
actividades intelectuales la que
protegía a las gentes inteligentes las
que les daba inteligencia y sabiduría
etcétera etcétera etcétera
pero
todos los que han leído la odisea el
gran poema de homero saben perfectamente
que el héroe que allí se protagoniza
todas esas aventuras es el héroe
ulises es uno de héroe protegido por esa
por esa diosa por esa minerva atenea y
es un óleo héroe que se caracteriza
súper bien moderno que se caracteriza no
por la fuerza bruta sino que se
caracteriza precisamente por su
capacidad de ingeniar se soluciones
inteligentes para problemas complejos
que se le presentan
esto es una característica que debe
tener cualquier persona que quiere
iniciar cualquier actividad de
emprendimiento no tiene que estar
capacitada hay que pensar que va a tener
que resolver problemas complejos y que
los tiene que resolver con astucia con
inteligencia en este caso bueno pues
y tenemos a ulises que se ata al mástil
de sudario para escuchar el canto de las
sirenas y el canto de las sirenas
mientras que sus compañeros los remeros
les tapa los oídos con cera para poder
él ser el único mortal que escucha los
cantos de las sirenas sin correr riesgos
pero mientras tanto su mujer le está
esperando en casa diez años de guerra
diez años de viaje veinte años
el héroe fuera de casa pero penélope que
está siendo constantemente asediada por
nuevos pretendientes que quieren casarse
con ella para poderse hacer con el trono
de ítaca de la ciudad de la isla en la
que reinaba ulises pues penélope sigue
constante sigue fiel sigue comprometida
con su palabra de fidelidad que le había
dado a su esposo ulysses lo espera
durante 20 años y urde también una
estrategia decirle a los pretendientes
yo
me casaré con vosotros ya escogeré a uno
a uno de vosotros pero lo haré cuando
haya acabado de tejer este sudario que
estoy haciendo para mi suegro laertes
que es muy anciano y lo que tenía de día
lo destejía de noche para no acabar
nunca no bueno todos tenemos que saber
que para iniciar cualquier actividad
tenemos que tener en el laberinto de la
vida este laberinto que tenemos aquí
representado donde tenemos que que
tenemos que recorrerlo pero tenemos que
arreglarlo con un criterio con sentido
bueno pues es conveniente llevar un plan
y ese plan es ese hilo de ariadna ese
hilo que le da la princesa cretense
ariadna a teseo para que pueda entrar en
el laberinto matar al menos tauro y
salir fuera y todos sabemos gracias al
mito de los argonautas que es preferible
cuando iniciamos una actividad de
emprendimiento una aventura importante
trabajar en equipo
es preferible somos capaces de llegar
más lejos a cosas más importantes es
mucho más es conveniente hacerlo en
equipo y sobre todo también el valor de
la amistad el ejemplo de la amistad de
aquiles y de patroclo es un ejemplo que
ha iluminado frecuentemente a las gentes
de todo occidente pero también tenemos
que saber qué
en la vida hay peligros hay
inconvenientes y tenemos que saber
sortear los uno de los peligros más
frecuentes es el engreimiento el
narcisismo ahí tenemos a narciso ese
joven tan hermoso que consideraba que
había ninguna mujer digna de él y un día
se contempló en las limpias aguas de una
fuente se enamoró de sí mismo quiso
poseer se y se ahogó en la fuente no el
narcisismo es uno de los peligros que a
él la avaricia el rey midas que le pidió
a los dioses que le concedieran poder
convertir en oro todo lo que tocara y se
quedó sin poder comer o sí si fue que
está condenado a iniciar un trabajo una
y otra vez o bien el caso de ícaro que
quiso subir a los cielos no escuchando
los consejos de su padre y qué
al acercarse al sol pues el sol le
derritió la cera de sus alas y cayó y
murió la altanería la soberbia otro de
los peligros o por fin la calumnia las
peñas los mitos clásicos nos enseñan
como también la mentira y la calumnia en
el caso estévez hipólito y fedra
la suegra que se enamora del hijo del
hijastro y que es no es correspondida
termina acabando bueno pues estas
calumnias estas mentiras pueden acabar
también con la vida de cualquiera no con
la empresa que cualquiera bueno todos
estos mitos nos ilustran sobre montones
de cosas a mí me gustaría tener tiempo y
estoy seguro de los dos también para
poderlos contar más despacio algunas de
estas historias muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]